marco ferrer vous sortez un film
s'appelle via bon les blancs c'est un
joli titre quand même temps c'est vous
qui avez trouvé ça non pas moi c'est qui
qu'a trouvé ça moi j'ai pensé utile que
c'est comme sur le bolivien qui j'ai
fait traduire et
les garçons que la traduit et en
français s'en sort mieux et la bia bon
le pas ce serait très dur pour ça c'est
du tout ça c'est du colonialisme quoi
pour vous je veux dire le le fait de
vouloir que d'être vives absolument
commun qui mangent du pain qu'ils
mangent de la farine de poisson oui la
farine de poisson c'est vraiment non la
fin du morceau a appris ces horribles
fin juin ces choses franchement horrible
c'est horrible déjà pour les chefs la
farine de poisson qui reste après qu'on
a fait manger léger on l'appelle e all
in one et ont la pêche en face de la
frime et légumes pèserait pas sur la
maine on ramène ont fait de la farine à
laval haleine avec la même issue
d'amérique après on la ramène en afrique
comme la farine des passagers et je suis
pas contre les aides je suis pas contre
les médecins je suis pas contre à moi
les restaurants du coeur les décors les
restaurants de l'abbé pierre gecko je
suis content
une système qui détermine ça je suis
quand j'ai moi à la télévision que
publicis caramy
hier soir il y avait quarante mille
bugis qui ça représente 4000 enfants qui
meurent chaque jour dans le même temps
puis l'ont pas fait ressortir les
montagnes des blés les photos de les
montagnes de blé des photos de montagne
de maïs les photos de montagne début de
burke est ce à ce réseau le plus les
surplus hong hong et touchent pas pour
retracer les pouvoirs la carité c'est
une pépite façon alors je suis contre ça
on va passer à un autre ami kouchner
alors bernard comme on va christine
ockrent et votre petite amie que dans la
tête on va se marier le 29 avril
bravo ça va merci à dieu et alexandre
danset l'alliage vous remercie alors il
ya quelques années dans clarté vous avez
écrit que pour être rastignac fallait
être communiste et l'année dernière vous
avez écrit dans le monde qui aujourd'hui
reste miens qui émarge à la croix rouge
c'est quand même pas étonnant que
ferreri soit un peu énervé par tout ça
non tout ça est pas du tout énervé par
l'avant je me souviens pas d'avoir écrit
dans le monde qu rastignac qui marche à
la croix ou alors ça m'a échappé ou si
c'est une 23e peuvent faire preuve ainsi
émargé à la grande aujourd'hui rastignac
émarge à la croix rouge ce qui veut dire
une histoire plus alors mais rastignac
est passé comme ça deux du parti
communiste à la croix rouge que qui a un
temps pour la guerre et un temps pour
l'humanité c'est vrai que la découverte
du monde qui s'est fait un peu par les
idéologies pardon d'être un peu grave
maintenant se fait par la découverte du
rêve du réel et cet autre chose et sont
des gens qui vont rencontrer d autres
qui les rencontre pas forcément bien
comme le raconte marco dans son film qui
les rencontre peut-être mieux qu'il le
dit parfois est en tout cas les
différences sont toujours très grandes
et moi je pense qu'il faut se parler se
rencontrer au salon peuvent pas faire la
guerre après ouais
- on s'est affronté vraiment faim
finalement vous êtes pas choqué par le
fil de fer et moi je souhaite choqué 84
et ferreri raconte une opération celle
où les gens se disent comment ça marche
l'opération
bon si ces gens là bas aussi je dois
parler avec lui
de quoi du trade est l'occasion des
défis c'est à nous de nous on est d
organiser des spécialistes
c'est comme si vous parlez avec des
dentistes de vous et choqué des comités
la première d'un film sur les médecins
l'ordre des médecins moi je suis pas
l'ordre de la charité je m'en fous je
fais ça parce que ça m'amuse parti faire
marco fait un film parce que ça
l'amusait la farq où il dit quand même
qu'aujourd'hui les gens qui font ce
genre de truc c'est une forme de
néocolonialisme crois qu'il n'a pas
toujours raison et il a parfois raison
il est vrai que la forme avec laquelle
la charité et fait la charité au sens
comme ça un tout petit peu gringalet qui
attira caricaturale du terme peut
ressembler peut ressembler à ça et en
tout cas les conséquences de cette aide
là sont très souvent une forme de
colonialisme mal comprise il est certes
un tout simplement que quand on amène de
la viande casher dans un endroit où les
gens ont des difficultés à manger de la
viande à la manche et surtout les
paysans à vendre leur viande sur le
marché ont démoli le marché frémit en
innovation la ville a bien que
il va distribuer et on l'a payé ouais on
ne trouve pas notre système économique
on ne touche pas à mes va lâcher parce
que si on touchait on écroulerait
l'ensemble c'est ça qu'il faudrait faire
ses valises et de boisés encore nous
sommes pas loin l'un de l'autre
c'est vrai mars comme on est voisins
pourquoi on est riche pour ça on peut
parler de la chari et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou